[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález desde el pasado
28 de abril las calles de las ciudades
colombianas han sido el escenario de
nutridas manifestaciones ciudadanas que
han tenido lugar por las propuestas a
una propuesta de una reforma fiscal por
parte del presidente iván duque una
reforma que ante el rechazo de los
colombianos fue completamente retirada
pero el descontento ciudadano se ha
mantenido y si hay una ciudad que se ha
convertido en el reflejo de la situación
es cali que es la capital del
departamento del valle del cauca un polo
industrial agrícola también comercial de
gran importancia para colombia y sobre
todo para la región del sur occidente
del país pronto los retenes ilegales los
enfrentamientos las muertes el miedo
ciudadano el abuso policial las
agresiones vandalismo y también el
desabastecimiento se tomaron esta ciudad
porque qué factores han hecho de cali el
epicentro de la manifestación ciudadana
en colombia tal vez porque esta ciudad
la tercera de importancia en colombia es
radiografía exacta de la sociedad
colombiana dividida desigual y
descontenta en el debate de france 24
hablamos de cali retrato de la colombia
que protesta y para analizar este tema
hemos invitado a jorge sánchez el ex
coordinador político del consejo
regional indígena del cauca él se
encuentra en la ciudad de popayán
capital del departamento del cauca en el
sur occidente del país y también está
con nosotros el representante a la
cámara por el partido centro democrático
gabriel vallejo él se encuentra en la
ciudad de pereira en risaralda en el
corazón de la zona cafetera colombiana
lee es el recuerdo que ustedes también
hacen parte de esta conversación pueden
dejar sus preguntas y comentarios en las
redes sociales en la recuerdo estamos en
facebook también no se encuentran en
instagram y en twitter como arroba
france24
y arroba santi lobo la etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 tenemos allí
más información para darles referente a
este tema debido a las noticias que han
trascendido a lo largo de la semana
referente a las manifestaciones en cali
en otras ciudades
pues bien vamos a comenzar tenemos ya
los invitados listos y comienzo entonces
por el representante vallejo en la
ciudad de pereira comienzo por
preguntarle en para la audiencia que
está fuera de las fronteras colombianas
cuáles son las características que tiene
cali que la han hecho una ciudad
particular para el epicentro de estas
manifestaciones ciudadanas tal parece
que todos los ingredientes se han
reunido allí
bueno un saludo para todos muchas
gracias de santiago feliz noche para la
audiencia de france 24
qué ocurre cali es la tercera ciudad de
colombia ubicada en el occidente del
país en lo que se conoce como el
pacífico colombiano
y que particularmente históricamente ha
venido teniendo unos problemas sociales
muy complejos por un lado tiene una
fuerte migración de las poblaciones
ubicadas en la costa pacífica población
fundamentalmente negra a su vez tiene en
su límite en la frontera con el cauca un
departamento digamos con un porcentaje
muy importante de población indígena
y lo que ha ocurrido es que en mi
opinión las condiciones sociales de esa
ciudad que es una ciudad importantísima
insisto por encima de los 2 millones de
habitantes ha hecho que el clima de
protesta sea mayor que en otras que en
otras que en otras ciudades del país
el tema por supuesto narcotráfico el
narcotráfico sigue siendo un grave
problema para este país
y la pobreza cali es una ciudad en donde
los índices de pobreza en algunos
sectores de la ciudad son más altos que
en muchas partes del país y esto ha
hecho que la situación de la situación
social se ponga tensa y que se haya
derivado en unas protestas legítimas por
un lado pero que agitadores esto esto
ha derivado en que agitadores en que
influencia de grupos al margen de la ley
protestas que han venido de otros
departamentos grandes movilizaciones
pues haya perdido el coach haga perdió
el control y se haya derivado en hechos
de vandalismo y terrorismo que
obviamente preocupan pero insisto son
las condiciones particulares de cali que
generan esta situación tan crítica para
todo colo que es paradójico ver que
antes del inicio de la pandemia del
joven 19 cali en todos estos indicadores
que usted ha mencionado de pobreza de
pobreza extrema e índice de desigualdad
tenía unos porcentajes mucho mejores que
los que presentaba colombia a nivel
nacional sólo por mencionar algunos por
ejemplo la tasa de pobreza era de 21.9
frente al 35.7 que se presenta a nivel
nacional la pobreza extrema era de 4.7 y
a nivel nacional de 19.6 y el índice de
desigualdad 0.46 por ciento frente al
0.52 por ciento
este escenario cambió por completo
después de la pandemia del cob y 19
todos estos indicadores aumentaron jorge
sánchez en la ciudad de popayán
no muy lejos de allí de la ciudad de
cali solamente a un par de horas de
viaje desde la capital del valle del
cauca su opinión frente al panorama que
se presenta en cali y estamos hablando
de los ingredientes que se congregan
allí para generar este malestar y esta
crisis social
un saludo
de resistencia desde el cauca y la radio
france 24 igualmente al doctor vallejo
que se encuentra en la ciudad de pereira
consideramos de que no pero el viejo ha
hecho una radiografía interesante sin
embargo los singles de pobreza no
solamente en cali final del país cali
hoy se convierte en el epicentro de la
movilización de las protestas porque ahí
se trata de mostrar quizá digamos la
ciudad bonita la ciudad de la salsa la
capital de la alegría sin embargo
el factor que revienta digamos a la
movilización en las calles es como
los factores de pobreza la poca tensión
que le ha colocado el gobierno a esta
población pero igualmente al cero
siguiente el país para todo el pacífico
pero asimismo el tema narcotráfico bros
el tema del narcotráfico ha sido un
ingrediente que
y ha ayudado a que cierta manera este
tema se empiece a polarizar asimismo los
grupos ilegales
igualmente cali se convierte en un
corredor un corredor hacia el mar hacia
el puerto en aventura y aquí convergen
digamos el tema de la economía donde el
cual se mueve pero así aquí convergen
otros pueblos como nosotros que de
cierta manera los pueblos indígenas
llegan a este espacio porque se puede
cómo se convierte en un centro comercial
interesante al sur del país y estos
elementos son los que conjugan para
poder digamos hay un levantamiento a
nivel del país hoy hay un levantamiento
social y este levantamiento social es
por los índices de pobreza es la poca o
la falta de políticas públicas para
atender la población más vulnerable
la inversión que se centra en los
grandes poblados y no en las periferias
y otro factor que afecta es qué
la gobernabilidad se centra hacia el
centro y no insistieron mucho hacia las
periferias por eso colombia tiene una
diferentes contextos dos contextos son
urbanos son rurales y esa realidad tiene
campesinos tiene indígenas en los
poblados tienen los barrios que de
cierta manera también están aislados del
desarrollo y están aislados de los
modelos que quizás se implantan para
poder forzar digamos una economía un
modelo de desarrollo por eso cali hoy el
levantamiento que se hace lo hace en los
barrios lo hace la gente lo hacen los
transportadores lo hace
los jóvenes los estudiantes porque las
periferias están abandonadas y ahí se
encuentran con este factor que quizá
está penetrando en las ciudades
insistimos mucho el tema del
narcotráfico la pobreza y los grupos
armados que quizá digamos también hacen
presente en estos sitios representante
vallejo continúa la ronda con usted
preguntándole siendo entonces casi una
especie de radiografía que ustedes
mismos han construido acá de lo que
sucede en colombia de ese sentir de los
colombianos ese malestar que usted
entonces que estas marchas van a tener
una prolongación en el tiempo que este
paro va a persistir y que cali seguirá
siendo entonces ese epicentro de las
negociaciones de los paros de los
retenes ilegales y de toda la serie de
inseguridad que se estaba presentando
allí a lo largo de estos días
santiago yo yo quería para contestarte
la pregunta quiero también a adicionar
algo importante cali tiene una posición
estratégica en colombia recuerden los
los televidentes que el puerto de
buenaventura ubicado en el pacífico
colombiano
muy cerca cali es el principal puerto de
entrada de del comercio internacional en
colombia y eso pone un elemento
adicional es decir aquí tampoco es que
sea casualidad que que las protestas y
esto que se está viviendo en colombia
simplemente es por cerca de una ciudad
digamos con índices de pobreza con
problemas de narcotráfico entonces esto
por supuesto insisto porque aquí
por lo menos yo creo que además del
descontento ciudadano para contestar su
pregunta que claro que es legítimo
histórico además esto no es que
simplemente hay un descontento en contra
del gobierno no aquí hay un descontento
acumulado de décadas
de un abandono del sector agropecuario
el problema de desempleo juvenil es un
problema sumamente grave el problema el
problema sanitario el problema la salud
que lo agrava además el tema de la
pandemia
yo creo santiago que el problema no está
por resolverse pronto uno esperaría que
las mesas de diálogo nos ayuden a bajar
la temperatura nos ayuden a bajarle el
nivel de tensión tan grande que existe
cuál es realmente pues además el
problema es que estas protestas hay que
entender que por un lado hay
protestantes que salen de manera
pacífica legítima pero adicionalmente
hay un vandalismo y un terrorismo de
mediana densidad y infiltrado en estas
en estas protestas que hacen que empiece
a generar su nivel de tensión ya eso hay
que sumarle unos bloqueos bloqueos de
vías que empiezan a generar
desabastecimiento de combustibles
desabastecimiento de materia prima
desabastecimiento de alimentos
yo creo que si no se logra eliminar
rápidamente el tema de bloqueos y el
tema de vandalismo en la protesta hombre
esto esto no no pinta nada bien y
confiamos en que los canales de diálogo
ayuden a generar e insisto cuáles son
las propuestas estructurales esto no es
una negociación tan sencilla de que es
que se está pidiendo un aumento salarial
o se está pidiendo un punto x oye esto
requiere unas reformas estructurales que
están pidiendo los colombianos
y que requieren de un gran acuerdo
nacional de los diferentes sectores de
la vida democrática colombiana señor
jorge sánchez en popayán para las
personas que están fuera del territorio
colombiano resulta llamativo cuando lo
decíamos a través de las noticias lo
dijimos aquí en france24 cuando
anunciamos que grupos indígenas venían
desde el departamento del cauca en una
movilización hacia cali a unirse a estas
manifestaciones ciudadanas pacíficas
para poner en contexto porque tenía que
estar allí los grupos indígenas en cali
que representan ustedes allí que
reclamaban ustedes al gobierno porque
también ya reportamos que muchos
regresaron a los resguardos después de
los incidentes que hubo el fin de semana
en donde varios indígenas resultaron
heridos en unos enfrentamientos que
todavía no están muy claros por parte de
las autoridades y tampoco es claro para
los medios de comunicación
el tema el tema en cali en colombia es
un problema estructural aquí partimos de
ese elemento es un problema que hay que
revisarlo
seguramente no en el momento pero si
toca sentarse a revisar una problemática
que es de fondo
y ese problema no se arregla simplemente
firmando un cheque o generando unos
recursos y revisarla en la estructura la
política y los desarrollos que se
quieran hacer con participación de la
gente
segundo cal y cuando ya arranca el
proceso de movilización empiezan a ver
empiezan a ver muertos
empiezan a ver muchos heridos y no una
atención inmediata de parte del gobierno
y ahí nosotros por estar muy cercano y
estar en la misma movilización nosotros
acudimos a acompañar a esos jóvenes a
acompañar a los estudiantes y con la
experiencia que se tiene en este proceso
de 50 años que llevamos de proceso a
nivel del cauca en resistencia en los
desarrollos que venimos haciendo
acompañamos igualmente nuestra labor
defender la vida porque es que la
estaban matando a los estudiantes están
matando a los que están en la
movilización y allí acudimos en eso en
dos contenidos en uno a defender la vida
y en otro para ayudar a aportarles el
aportes nosotros nosotros lo que hicimos
la compañía regresaba sin embargo se
malentendió y finalmente entraron a
agredirnos y entraron
en concreto la fuerza pública en
relación con personas
civiles pensaron agredir y ahí se
convierte lo que se ve el pasado domingo
que finalmente termina tiene un asunto
desde el 9 completamente lo que es cómo
se estaba viviendo en cali pero cómo es
la situación del país es que el tema de
cali en la roh grafía que se presenta a
nivel del país y con eso queda claro que
hay vidente varias situaciones primero
el tema de la movilización en colombia
hoy se trata de criminalizar se trata de
cerrar el paso a ese ejercicio y segundo
el tema de la procesa hoy se trata de
dirigir a un asunto meramente coyuntural
y el tema no es cultural el tema de
estructural
tercero la situación del acompañamiento
nuestro en el contenido insistimos mucho
de poder digamos
valorar la vida y valorar la línea y
finalmente nosotros regresamos
nuevamente a el cauca y no regresamos
porque el presidente lo digo regresamos
porque cumplimos una tarea y nosotros
regresamos porque vamos a reorganizar
todo el trabajo y seguiremos avanzando
en este ejercicio de la movilización
social considerando el ejercicio que
estamos atentos a poder atender a
conversar y a poder que generamos una
discusión política de fondo y no
meramente un asunto central como se
quiere es sí
representante vallejo recojo varias
cosas de esta intervención de jorge
sánchez desde la ciudad de popayán es
una manifestación que quiere ir más allá
lo decía el no coyunturales estructural
y estos enfrentamientos que hubo en cali
el fin de semana está
partida de los grupos indígenas y el
regreso a sus resguardos indígenas en el
cauca y estos choques entre fuerza
pública ciudadanía armada contra los
indígenas refleja ese malestar histórico
que hay en colombia este racismo es el
clasismo que parece que no va a sanar
vuelve y queda en evidencia a nivel
social eso en colombia
pero no o santiago yo yo creo que en
colombia y lo digo con franqueza esta es
una sociedad en donde yo no siento que
haya por ejemplo xenofobia o racismo
particularmente frente a grupos étnicos
o digamos sociales yo yo creo que ahí
nos radica el problema en el caso de los
indígenas en donde digamos que desde
hace muchos años han venido haciendo
unos reclamos
de digamos de tierras a reclamos de
inversiones de infraestructura digamos
que es han sido sus reclamaciones
históricas que se han presentado a los
diferentes gobiernos yo realmente creo
que el matiz de lo que se vivió en cali
el fin de semana no tiene nada que ver
ni con xenofobia ni con racismo en
absoluto lo que se vivió en cali el fin
de semana era uno por supuesto veníamos
de unos días de manifestaciones que
vuelvo y repito santiago esto es
importante que los televidentes lo los
televidentes lo entiendan habían unas
manifestaciones pacíficas legítimas
fueron infiltradas por actores
terroristas y de vandalismo es decir en
colombia tuvimos daños a bienes públicos
a infraestructura pública en colombia
tuvimos atentados de lo que se conoce en
el mundo como terrorismo de baja de baja
escala oa la densidad eso hace haber
sumado al tema los bloqueos santiago es
el tema de los bloqueos al final termina
generando una situación de orden público
muy compleja porque las ciudades
empiezan a no tener combustible las
filas de las estaciones de servicio eran
interminables 8 horas para echar
gasolina mejor dicho el mejor modelo de
socialismo que tenemos aquí al lado lo
estamos viviendo en colombia que era
venezuela lo estábamos viviendo en
colombia ese tipo de situaciones hace
que el nivel de tensión por supuesto se
incremente y al llegar la minga indígena
a la ciudad de cali en un momento tan
tensionante pues cualquier chispa
enciende
a las confrontaciones eso en mi opinión
fue lo que se vivió el fin de semana en
donde hubo hechos desafortunados
y que al final los generaron mucha
angustia pero no yo creo que no tiene
nada que verse con temas ni el clasismo
ni de racismo ni de xenofobia yo creo
que colombia sin querer decir que no
existe pero pero yo creo que ese no es
el problema el problema realmente tiene
que ver en donde se confluyen muchos
problemas históricos valga la
redundancia pero insisto tenemos
terrorismo tenemos vandalismo y los
bloqueos
obviamente generan violencia y una
violencia que exaspera a la ciudadanía
que no sale a protestar hago esta
pregunta para los dos y comienzo por
jorge para que la responda desde su
perspectiva jorge quienes pueden haber
infiltrado estas marchas como lo decía
el representante vallejo eran
completamente legítimas pacíficas y
desencadenaron unos hechos de violencia
no solamente en cali hubo también otros
hechos importantes de vandalismo en
bogotá y también en la ciudad de pereira
donde está el representante vallejo
para usted quien las puede haber
infiltrado
y lo primero que hay que entender es que
el tema como lo ve el gobierno mirad es
digamos como que si fuera la protesta
nos iluminan los hechos del vandalismo
y el problema digamos que se mira a
veces desde la parte central del
gobierno es un problema de si estamos de
acuerdo la necesidad que hay de un tema
de abastecimiento de gasolina pero no
miran desde el punto de vista puntual y
ahí se llevan digamos el asunto digamos
de la discusión el asunto de la
exclusión insistimos es un asunto de
fondo es un asunto estructural es una
aclaración y es una síntesis rural para
el país no solamente para cal es la poca
atención que le ha dado el gobierno a
las periferias a nivel de colombia y
sobre todo a nivel del sur el siguiente
que definitivamente está
se ha incrementado el narcotráfico o los
grupos armados porque hay un tema aquí
concreto el gobierno ha vuelto trizas el
acuerdo de paz y finalmente llegó la
guerra en los terrestres primero segundo
el asunto de quienes infiltró las
movilizaciones hay un tema clarito cómo
se ve el gobierno quiso romper las
movilizaciones y buscó una estrategia
concreta a través de la fuerza pública
de querer romper y que desestructuran
las mediciones para mostrar el ejercicio
del vandalismo como se muestra a nivel
internacional y afuera que aquí la
movilización es un acto vandálico y eso
está demostrado con los vídeos y no no
podemos decir que eso y nosotros la
minga indígena cogimos muchos y varios
militares y estuvieron en la minga y era
infiltrado y eran los que generaban el
desorden adentro y al general de sobre
el adentro rompe digamos del esquema y
empieza digamos a mostrarse para vender
al mundo otra imagen ese es una
estructura y terminó diciendo lo que
pasa es que la xenofobia si se ha
generado desde el gobierno y aquí hay
unos pinos concretamente desde especie
que es presidente uribe donde mandan los
mensajes para poder digamos que verán la
xenofobia hacia los grupos de indígenas
y querer
pero digamos un tejido social pero es
que en colombia muestran quieren mostrar
como si fueran un venezuela pero en
venezuela y no me quiero referir a ese
asunto pero en colombia estamos viviendo
igual y quizá ha aparecido en otros
países que los indios pobres que no
están siendo atendidos porque se
entiende digamos a un acierto digamos
intereses y no a los intereses de un
colectivo representante vallejo su
opinión al respecto
santiago digamos que no me queda claro
la respuesta que hace joven porque al
final no terminó explicando quienes
infiltran las protestas es decir es es
absolutamente incontrovertible santiago
es incontrovertible la infiltración de
terrorismo de baja densidad y de
vandalismo en estas protestas que por
supuesto terminan deslegitimando las
cuando uno tiene una protesta pacífica y
permite que se infiltren vándalos y
terroristas pues al final se mezcla
entre la protesta pacífica legítima que
es un derecho fundamental derecho humano
fundamental el salir a protestar dar de
manera pacífica
eso eso hace que esto es que cuando se
permite esta infiltración pues
obviamente pues el estado tiene que
salir a repeler ya no la protesta
pacífica porque deja de ser pacífica
deja de ser pacífica tiene que repeler
una protesta que se derivó en actos de
vandalismo y terrorismo insisto quema de
bienes públicos de buses y otro elemento
adicional santiago que no es un tema
menor el bloqueo a las vías aquí hay que
decirle al mundo que lo que tú vocal y
lo que tiene pereira en este momento es
bloqueo a las ciudades no permiten
llegar alimentos no permiten llegar
medicinas no permiten llegar el cloro ni
los elementos para potabilizar el agua
es decir tienen sitiada a las ciudades
colombianas y eso perdóneme santiago no
es protesta pacífica eso se llama
terrorismo y ese terrorismo es el que ha
generado un clima muy tenso entre
quienes salen a protestar pacíficamente
que por supuesto hay que protegerles y
garantizarles su protesta pacífica pero
también hay que diferenciarlos de
quienes quieren sembrar terror y generar
un clima de desestabilización política
en colombia para
y pescar en río revuelto entendiendo
además que estamos ya en vísperas de
unas elecciones presidenciales en el año
2022 representante vallejo pero
retomando lo que usted dice hablando de
estos retenes y estos bloqueos que se
han presentado en diferentes ciudades
del país entonces donde quedan las
autoridades locales donde quedan los
alcaldes dónde queda la capacidad del
gobierno de hacer presencia esto deja
claro esa poca capacidad que tiene el
gobierno colombiano de hacer presencia
en territorios apartados pero aquí lo
estamos viendo en perfecto ejemplo en
las grandes ciudades
claro yo digamos que ese es un reclamo
ese es un reclamo histórico santiago de
digamos del centralismo colombiano y es
cuál es el control que tiene el gobierno
en un territorio tan complejo tan grande
con una topografía digamos difícil como
la colombiana para manejar el orden
público para garantizar la seguridad a
los 50 millones de colombianos para
garantizarle la vida la libertad y la
propiedad los colombianos ese ha sido un
tema que en mi opinión pues tiene
digamos que nos ayuda un momento de
angustia del país porque aquí tienen en
jaque y tomó el ejemplo de pereira en
pereira hasta hace dos días un
territorio de más de dos millones de
habitantes santiago dos millones de
habitantes
no teníamos combustible y usted sabe que
es para un territorio de dos millones de
colombianos no tener combustible y cómo
movilizarse ese tipo de situaciones hace
que por supuesto pues el reclamo de la
ciudadanía de recuperación del orden
público
de remover y levantar los bloqueos
porque este aquí no este que negociar
nada uno con alguien que bloquea una
vida y que impide el suministro de
oxígeno para los hospitales que impide
el suministro de alimentos no hay que
negociar nada hay que es judicial izarlo
porque está cometiendo un delito ese es
parte de las reclamaciones que muchos de
los colombianos hacen y que por supuesto
le solicitan al gobierno nacional que es
el levantamiento inmediato de los
bloqueos los bloqueos no hacen parte de
la protesta pacífica
eso no es protesta pacífica un bloqueo
que bloquea una ciudad perdóneme pues es
un acto prácticamente de terrorismo y
delitos o si quiero abordar otro tema
con los dos y es el papel destacado que
han tenido los jóvenes en estas
manifestaciones ciudadanas el liderazgo
y la organización que han tenido para
salir a las calles a hacer diferentes
reclamos es una generación que va a
tener un futuro muy difícil que ya pues
simplemente por el hecho de ser
colombianos y recibir acá ya era un
futuro complicado por las condiciones
que tiene este país por su
tradición y por su contexto histórico
del conflicto armado jorge su
perspectiva sobre el papel que han
tenido los jóvenes y este cambio de
generación en cuanto al país que ellos
quieren y que están reclamando y que tal
parece que las generaciones más viejas
digámoslo así no están dispuestas a
ceder
los jóvenes han jugado un papel y juegan
un papel importante hoy en esta
generación y la regeneración de la nueva
sociedad se llama lo así en colombia
pero aquí aparece un problema si el
joven hoy se levanta si el joven hoy hoy
empieza digamos a reclamar unos derechos
si es joven hoy levanta esa voz y se
juntan en un solo grito y hoy es que es
hoy no es un asunto de la mujer lección
en colombia porque hay una estructura
organizada no la gente se levantó la
gente salió a las calles los jóvenes
sobre todos los jóvenes porque se
cansaron de una una hegemonía
centralista y se cansaron de un poder
que finalmente una estructura de
políticas más ligadas a tratar de
defender los intereses particulares de
las de un modelo económico y no los
intereses de la población
y la juventud tiene un valor fundamental
y tiene un valor en el sentido que
quiere digamos forjarse un camino y
tratar de generar una nueva política a
nivel del país pero que aparece un
problema y ese joven que genera digamos
una iniciativa de levantarse pero
finalmente digamos atrás se trata de
estructurar la movilidad social y a eso
se le llama terrorismo a eso se le llama
terrorismo cuál es el futuro de esta
juventud claro que tiene un futuro muy
complicado porque la agresión va a ser
una arremetida iba a ser digamos la
criminalización de la protesta es que
aquí el concepto de terrorismo es un
concepto para atacar la movilización es
un concepto que genera digamos la
violencia porque lo está generando para
querer romper digamos deambulación y
tratar de que los jóvenes no nos sigan
el camino por eso es el tema de los
jóvenes hoy la movilización se está
moviendo porque los jóvenes muchos
jóvenes están saliendo a las calles y
quieren generar digamos una política y
quieren generar una nueva visión y un
nuevo modelo a nivel del país y eso
en la juventud trazarse hacia un nuevo
camino mejor es claro es claro su punto
jorge allí en la ciudad de popayán
representante vallejo su opinión
representante no lo estamos oyendo creo
que le ha puesto
la pena no estoy de acuerdo con lo
planteado por jorge que además denota
claramente un sesgo ideológico y de
manipulación ideológica hacia los
jóvenes problema a los jóvenes no es un
reclamo frente al modelo económico hay
un desconocimiento de por qué los
jóvenes están saliendo a protestar en
donde efectivamente hay un problema
estructural
santiago que se resume en empleo es
decir colombia los jóvenes entre 18 y 28
años es el sector de la población con
mayor desempleo por encima del 22 o 23
por ciento ese es uno de los motivos más
graves que hoy de los problemas más
graves que tiene hoy colombia y que por
supuesto genera en mi opinión esta
movilización de los jóvenes cuando uno
le pregunta a los jóvenes cuáles son los
principales problemas que yo le ven al
país le digo los tres el primero el
empleo de los jóvenes el segundo el
acceso a la educación superior y tercero
la lucha contra la pobreza pero no es un
tema como dice volvió frente al modelo
con
esa es una manipulación ideológica los
jóvenes están jugando un rol fundamental
en estas protestas porque al final lo
que están diciendo es oiga represento
nosotros tenemos una cobertura
importante en educación primaria y
secundaria pero cuando terminamos la
educación no estamos teniendo
oportunidades de empleo formal que es lo
que está ocurriendo y ahí es donde el
programa lamento tener que cortar y que
no para concluir su idea a jorge sánchez
le agradezco por haber estado con
nosotros desde popayán en el cauca ya
gabriel vallejo desde la ciudad de
pereira gracias por estar con nosotros
ustedes gracias por la sintonía
[Música]